this video is brought to you by lucy go
to lucy.com and use the promo code
biographics for 20
off your order today more on them in a
bit
the fourth dynasty of egypt is
considered a golden age for the ancient
civilization
perhaps even its most successful period
ever that's because it was a prosperous
chapter in egypt's history which
arguably gave the world
its most iconic landmarks of the ancient
world
the pyramids sometimes we associate
these structures with the entire time
span of the pharaohs also known as the
dynastic era which lasted for thousands
of years
in reality though most of the pyramids
were constructed in the early stages of
ancient egypt during the period known as
the old kingdom which only lasted for
around 500 years
the old kingdom stretched over four
different dynasties from the third to
the sixth but
it was the fourth dynasty that was
responsible for many of the megalithic
monuments that still stand today
this includes the greatest pyramid of
them all the pyramid of giza as well as
the sphinx that is why we'll be doing
something a bit different today we'll
not be looking at a single ruler mainly
because detailed information on any of
the old kingdom pharaohs is hard to come
by
instead we will be examining the entire
fourth dynasty composed of egypt's
greatest pyramid builders
before the construction of pyramids
pharaohs were still placed into royal
tombs which were called mastabas besides
the fact that these structures were
smaller they had one key characteristic
that distinguished them from the
pyramids they had a flat roof
the first pharaoh who was buried in
something that we would call a pyramid
was king de jose
from the third dynasty who quite
fittingly was the first pharaoh of the
old kingdom
initially his tomb was a large almost
square mastaba but his vizier imahotep
thought about placing another slightly
smaller mastaba
on top of that one and then another even
smaller one on top of that one and then
another
on top of that and so on in total there
were six mastabas placed on top of each
other
leading to the creation of egypt's first
pyramid the pyramid of de jose
also known as the steppe pyramid the
remaining pharaohs of the third dynasty
who followed de jose took similar
approaches with their royal tombs it
really seems like this whole pyramid
thing caught on big but
unfortunately they were still working
out the winning formula to building
pyramids none of their burial sites have
survived well into the modern era and
today
there are many ruins the last ruler of
the third dynasty pharaoh huni died
sometime around 2600 bc
thus making way for the fourth dynasty
to arrive and really show them how it's
done
the first pharaoh of the fourth dynasty
was sneferu sometimes called snorfu or
snarefruit historically records from
that time are not only incredibly sparse
but
they often contradict each other so we
can't provide you with accurate details
regarding his reign the best data we
have on him comes from a relic known as
the palermo stone a fragment of a steely
that contains rare and valuable
information on the first five dynasties
of egypt we know that sneferu had
a lengthy reign lasting for at least 24
years and maybe a lot longer than that
what we do not know are the
circumstances under which he became
pharaoh some believe he was the son of
king
huni while others contend that he held
an important position at huni's court
and ended up becoming pharaoh by
marrying his daughter heterferry's the
first who then went on to serve as
his great royal wife stefari's lengthy
reign was undoubtedly critical to the
successful completion of his ambitious
building projects however he still
needed a large workforce and plenty of
resources a lot more than he could find
in egypt that is why
according to inscriptions on the palermo
stone sneferu led military expeditions
into nubia and libya he was successful
and returned from these incursions with
tons of valuable cedarwood
thousands of prisoners and tens of
thousands of cattle
sheep and goats to feed his growing
labor force with these resources nepheru
built three pyramids and kicked off in
earnest
ancient egypt's golden age of pyramids
all of them were constructed at a site
named
darsur the first one known as the maiden
pyramids or maiden pyramid different
spellings is believed to have been
originally ordered by pharaoh huni and
then finished by sneferu when his
predecessor did not have time to
complete it in his lifetime
its look is somewhat unique in ancient
egypt it started off as a step pyramid
like the ones before it but at some
point presumably under sneferu
an extension was added on the outside by
filling and encasing the steps in
limestone thus making it smooth-sided
this technique did not give the pyramid
a lot of stability though and it
collapsed soon after the second one also
has a distinct appearance that set it
apart from
other egyptian pyramids stepharu was
nothing if not an innovator the lower
half of the pyramid
was built at a 51 degree inclination
however for the upper half the angle of
incline decreased to 43 degrees
thus becoming visibly less steep because
of this unique feature this structure is
usually known as the bent pyramid
why exactly it was constructed like this
we're not sure remember this was before
the traditional version of the egyptian
pyramid had been established so it's
possible that sneferu and his architects
were
simply experimenting to reach the
perfect design that the pharaoh wanted
egyptologists think that it is more
likely that the ancient architects
learned from their mistakes from
the maiden pyramids and when they saw
that one starting to collapse they
adjusted the angle on the bend pyramid
mid construction to make it more gradual
to give the structure more stability
stepharo's third and final project
finally looks like the egyptian pyramids
we know and love
it had the right shape it had the smooth
sides and at a height of approximately
104 meters
it still stands as the fourth tallest
pyramid ever built in egypt
almost the exact same height as the bent
pyramid clearly the pharaoh was pleased
as it is generally believed that
sneferro used it as his royal tomb even
though his mummy was
long gone by the time we found it in
modern times it is called the red
pyramid
named for the reddish color of the
limestone used to build the bulk of the
structure it was in fact originally
white as
it was encased into a limestone like
many other egyptian pyramids but
since that material was much rarer and
more valuable almost all of it had
been removed and reused for other
construction projects
as you can see stefaro left behind quite
a legacy one that put the egyptian
civilization on track towards becoming
one of the most
famous most distinct and most enduring
cultures of ancient times
and this legacy was continued and
enhanced to an extreme degree by his
successor
king kufu
like most other details from that era
the succession from snafuru to kufu
is one big question mark we're not sure
when
or why the old pharaoh died or when his
son became the new pharaoh but
historical records like the turing king
list indicate that khufru
had a long reign of at least 23 years he
is sometimes identified by his greek
name
chaops and also sufis a name given to
him by an egyptian historian
called manetho who lived 2200 years
later but still represents one of our
main sources
for the early history of egypt details
of khufu's range are scarce but it seems
that he also had some modest military
ambitions and he continued his kingdom's
expansion into sinai some historians
mainly herodotus make
khufu out to be a cruel ruler who was
only interested in his building projects
and
he didn't care about his people while
this might be true herodotus also said
some things that were demonstrably false
which undermines his credibility a bit
such as a tributary of the nile being
diverted to flow into the pyramid to
create
a little island where the pharaoh was
buried the greek historian also claimed
that khufu forced one of his daughters
into prostitution to help finance his
ambitious construction project and
that each client had to pay one stone
block to be with her herodotus also
started the myth which is still
prevalent to this day that the great
pyramid was built by slaves even though
egyptologists have universally dismissed
this notion
for the past three decades they have
been excavating the workers village
which showed that the laborers lived in
good conditions they
ate quality food including lots of meat
and were given proper burials in tombs
located close to the pyramids themselves
while the work was undoubtedly very hard
and intense
such amenities would never have been
provided for slaves instead the bulk of
the workforce consisted of people who
came from poor families who
considered working on the pharaoh's
pyramid to be a noble and respectable
position
as well as farmers looking for work
outside of the growing season
but now let's talk about the one thing
that ensured
that an otherwise obscure ruler like
khufu became immortal in the history
books his great pyramid
the pharaoh chose the giza plateau as
the site of his royal tomb and
there he ordered the construction of the
tallest pyramid in history
originally it was a height of 147 meters
although it's lost 10 meters due to
erosion and vandalism
we should also stress that we said
tallest not largest as that second
distinction goes to the great pyramid of
cholula in mexico but even so
the pyramid of khufu remains a
tremendous landmark one that practically
defined the ancient era as one of the
seven wonders of the ancient world it
predated the others by at least
two thousand years and today it's the
only one that still stands
there is a lot to say about the great
pyramids there is so much in fact that
we already devoted an entire video to it
and the other pyramids at giza on our
sister channel geographic
so you can check that out if you want an
in-depth look at that ancient marble
as for us we still have four more
pharaohs to get through so
let's crack on but before we do crack on
let me tell you about our fantastic
sponsor today
lucy now you're sitting there at work
get back to work or in starbucks
watching this video i'm wondering well
who's lucy
well it's more of a what because lucy is
a nicotine gum now you might be thinking
nicotine gum what is this simon 1992
well no let me tell you lucy is on a
mission to produce a cleaner nicotine
alternative through their revolutionary
new gum now lucy was started by two
caltech scientists that felt that
traditional products just weren't
speaking to their generation
and just weren't as satisfying as they
could be two years of reformulation
and they've created a longer lasting and
better experience gum that comes in
three flavors
wintergreen pomegranate and cinnamon
lucy's mission is to reduce
tobacco-related harm to zero by creating
a future where nicotine products can
satisfy adult tobacco users
without tobacco look we all know that
smoking is bad for you
that's obvious and that is why lucy have
created a product that allows you to get
the buzz you're looking for without
tobacco go to lucy.com and use the promo
code biographics for 20
off your order that's lucy.colucy.co
or just click the link in the
description below and use the code
biographics to get 20
off just a warning that this product
contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
king kufu most likely died sometime
between 2575 and 2566
bc and was succeeded by his only son
jidaifera
also called reggie death it's also
believed that dodephra's mother was one
of the pharaoh's secondary wives and
that
the original heir prince khawab died
before khufu due to the scarcity of
information some scholars have not
dismissed the possibility that judeaphra
usurped the throne from his brother but
this
is all speculation one thing that was
remarkable about him was that his name
jidethra
meant enduring like ra the sun god he
was the first known pharaoh to adopt the
name of raar and declare himself
son of ra thus perhaps signaling the
start of a significant and long-lasting
evolution in the ancient egyptian
religion that focused on devotion to the
sun
indeed by the time of the next dynasty
rah had already become one of the most
important gods in the egyptian pantheon
this relationship that judeaphra had
with his predecessor and
more importantly with his successor is a
big mystery that has
changed over the decades and still
causes a big debate among
egyptologists he began construction on
his own pyramid but he did not do it at
giza
instead his site was located about eight
kilometers north at abu rawash so why
did he choose a different location the
pharaohs who followed him built their
pyramids at giza but during his time the
only structure located there
was khufu's great pyramid maybe
jidaifera felt that each pharaoh should
have his own sight maybe there was some
kind of quarrel between him
and khufu or maybe he simply didn't want
to stay in his father's shadow both
literally and figuratively we can only
really guess at this point
today the pyramid of judaism lies in
ruins but whether it was destroyed or
never actually completed is again a
point of contention
for decades the accepted version of the
story claimed that judeaphra
had some sort of split with his family
this is not the only reason why he
selected a different location for his
pyramid but also why his successor
refused to complete it
but modern evidence indicates that the
true story may have been different
for starters jadavra seems to have been
the one who completed khufu's
burial and took part in funerary rites
for his father suggesting there was no
ill will between them furthermore after
his own death it appears that a mortuary
cult in
judea's honor was maintained for years
which would also point to a cordial
relationship between him and his
successor it's not exactly
conclusive evidence but there simply
isn't sufficient proof to
say what really happened
jodephra was succeeded by kafra who is
also known as kafra and the greek
version
chefren he was not his predecessor's son
now in fact his father was also kufu so
judeaphra and kafra were most likely
half-brothers most signs indicate that
judaisra had a short reign of only eight
years possibly
one of the reasons why his pyramid was
unfinished another possible
and dare we say more plausible reason
was that kafra was simply too
preoccupied with his own pyramid to care
about that of his predecessor
as we'll soon become clear the pharaoh
had lofty ambitions that rivaled
perhaps even surpassed those of his
father so he couldn't waste his time and
resources
building tredera's pyramid fortunately
for him kapra had a lengthy reign of
approximately 25 years so he had time to
enact his construction plans he went
back to giza and built the pyramid of
kafra the second largest structure on
the plateau and the second largest
pyramid in egypt
overall at a height of around 136 metres
and a half it is slightly shorter than
the pyramid of khufu but it appears to
be the tallest of the group because it
was built on a 10 meter hybrid bedrock
kapha's pyramid
is easily distinguishable because of the
three it is the only one whose top still
includes
part of the original outer casing stones
the pharaoh's complex also contained
other structures such as a mortary
temple a valley temple and
a much smaller pyramid probably for his
royal wife but there is something else
there that is unique and almost as
famous as the pyramids themselves
the great sphinx of giza it is not
completely certain that the sphinx was
built on kaffer's orders but its
position
in front of his pyramid not to mention
the fact that many believe the sphinx
bears the pharaoh's likeness both
indicate that kafra was the one who
commissions this giant statue its true
purpose however remains somewhat of a
mystery as does the identity of the
person who destroyed the statue's nose
and beard there is a popular myth that
puts blame on napoleon claiming that he
destroyed the features with cannon fire
during his military campaign in egypt
however there are earlier historical
records of the sphinx that
mentioned the missing nose showing that
it had already been destroyed by the
time napoleon arrived on the scene
the third and final of the great
pyramids at giza belonged to kafra's
successor menkora
also known by his greek name mai keranos
it was most likely the son of kafra and
queen
carmen abetsui the first but again due
to a dearth of historical evidence we
can't say this for sure there is also a
name that appears
at this junction that has puzzled
egyptologists for
decades and that name is bikeris he is
included in the king list made by the
aforementioned historian minitho and
presented as a pharaoh who had a very
short reign between kafra
and menkora we know almost nothing else
about him and since picares
is a hellenized name and is not his
original egyptian one
scholars have speculated that he may
have been prince bakker a son of
jidethra who could have briefly become
pharaoh under the name baccarate some
have even gone further and claimed that
the unfinished pyramid at
zayed el iran which is really just a
shaft dug in a natural base of bedrock
would have been his if not for his
premature death all of this is plausible
but then again so is the possibility
that the carers never existed and
monitor was simply wrong
remember he lived two thousand years
later and his work already contains
other errors so it's not an
infallible source but let's go back to
menkora his pyramid is
by far the smallest of the three on the
giza plateau rising to a height of 65
meters it was less than
half of the other two built by kufu and
kafra however it is remarkable in
another way it has three smaller
satellite pyramids which were most
likely
intended for his queens kharpur's
pyramid also had a subsidiary but
that one was really tiny this shows that
the priorities might have shifted
somewhat if manchora truly cared only
about the grandness of his pyramid he
could have taken the stones used for the
other three pyramids and made his much
bigger his successor didn't even bother
with his own pyramid and this could
indicate that even before the fourth
dynasty ended the egyptians
might have already gotten over the whole
pyramid thing all their reasons could
have been more
practical in nature each pharaoh trying
to build a pyramid bigger than the last
was simply not a sustainable model
regardless of how prosperous the kingdom
was it is entirely possible that kufunka
nearly exhausted egypt's resources with
their two pyramids despite the smaller
scale of his project mencore did not
finish building it in his lifetime when
he died circa 2500 bc
only one of the satellite pyramids had
been completed and there was still work
to be done on his temples mankora
had a pretty lengthy reign too estimated
to be around 18 to 22 years
the fact that he didn't finish it could
be suggestive in and of itself
indicating that
either a building the pyramid was no
longer a priority or b the kingdom was
struggling to obtain the materials and
manpower necessary to complete
construction
mencoro was succeeded to the throne of
egypt by the sixth and final pharaoh of
the fourth dynasty who was another
enigmatic ruler
about whom we know next to nothing his
name was shep seskaf
and he was probably mencoro's son he had
a short reign between four and eight
years depending on the source
in that time he was basically known for
doing two things the first was finishing
the work on the temples of mencore
since that was where people came to
worship the deceased pharaoh the cult of
mencore lasted for around 300 years
showing that he had been quite popular
and
beloved as pharaoh the second thing
accomplished by shep zeskev was to build
his own royal tomb the mastabat el
farahun
or pharaoh's bench but as its name
indicates this
was not a pyramid but rather a mastaba
the older structure
used as a royal tomb by previous
dynasties sheskelf was the first and
only pharaoh of the fourth dynasty to
forego the pyramid in favor of a more
basic mastaba he also didn't build a
giza but rather in sakhara and there is
another difference spotted in his name
unlike the previous three pharaohs
shepherd's name no longer ended
in rare instead his name meant his soul
is noble and it did not contain a
reference to the sun god ra
or any other egyptian deity together
these departures from previous pharaohs
could suggest that shep zeskaff wanted
to
deviate from the traditions set by his
predecessors some scholars believed that
the pharaoh may have felt that the cult
of ra had become too powerful too fast
so he might have wanted to limit the
worship of the sun god this could also
be the reason why he didn't build a
pyramid
since it could have been perceived as a
symbol of ra sheskath might have had
some
grand ambitions to take his kingdom in a
completely new direction which were
halted due to his premature
death or better yet since we don't know
how shepzeskaff died
maybe it was these attempted changes
that caused his early demise
one thing we do know is that they didn't
stick after shep zeskap's death came the
fifth dynasty and most of the pharaohs
of the fifth dynasty had ra in their
names to show devotion to the sun god
they also resumed building pyramids
although
none of them attained the grandeur
established by the pharaohs of the
fourth dynasty
so i really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do hit that thumbs up
button don't forget to subscribe also
check out our fantastic sponsor lucy
link below and thank you for watching